having this man call in because i adore
him and i've been a long time friend of
mine he's also much cheaper than seeing
a psychiatrist
the host of the michael k show locally
in new york city which is the number one
rated sports talk show in that great
city
and also the long time voice of the new
york yankees my long-time friend michael
k here on the rich island show michael
help me
help me please well the fees have gone
up rich
wow i did not know that i get your
ratings so it matches your ratings is
that what you're saying
is that how it works i just think you
know postseason bigger problems
bigger price okay it seems fair oh what
do we start with first i didn't even
bring up the fact that you talked to
james dolan
um and by proxy that just pisses me off
um
that was such a long time ago you know
what he said you're the only one you
let talk to him you know
so i mean and you hold him to account
god bless you so all right let's go with
the
let's go with the yankees first uh all
right a
uh major conundrum on their hands it
looks like the rays are a better team
michael is that a fair
assessment to say um the yankees have
more talent the raise might be a better
team
i think this thing all unraveled and
it's not over yet
but it all unraveled when they just got
too cute by a half with the stunt they
pulled in game two
you don't need to do that you just don't
uh the rays have done
the opener situation because they don't
have enough starters
i mean either the yankees don't like
their starters or don't trust them but
they have starters so
i didn't understand that uh paul o'neill
on the yes post game yesterday
actually said that that move might have
unsettled the entire
roster where why do we have to do this
against this team we just destroyed them
in game one
we destroyed two really good indian
pitchers in the first two games
of the playoffs what are we doing this
for and yesterday might have been a
hangover
from game two so i said after game two
that if they end up losing the series
that will be the reason why that
everything just unspooled after that
so um i don't know i i added you on
twitter and you're a busy man i don't
know if you saw
my take on it that it was anti-yankee
the yankees don't do
openers the yankees take your starter
pay him 200 million dollars to be their
number two start in the playoffs that's
what the yankees do
and i did see that uh and and i said
this on my radio show which is almost
along
the same lines you know game two happens
yes
and they essentially it would be like
mike
tyson climbing into the ring against pee
wee herman
and then just as the fight's about the
story he goes
wait a minute we have to play jeopardy
we're not fighting let's let's play
jeopardy yes why would you do that why
do you need to do that and this is not
disrespect
to the tampa bay rays because as you
said they're a very very good team but
the yankees are a
fully operational death star according
to brian cashman and you have to play
cute games with davey garcia and jay
happ
and the best thing that came out of that
was a story in the times by tyler kepner
and he dug up a quote from hindbloom
who used to be a member of the tampa bay
ray staff and he said the only way the
opener works
is if you get everybody to buy in
completely
if they don't buy in then it mitigates
whatever advantage you might have
well it's clear j hat didn't buy in
yeah he did it but he told them he
didn't want to do it so if
if if j half the 37 year old doesn't buy
in
why are you doing it so why did they do
it
i think they got too cute by a half and
and the juice wasn't worth the squeeze
to me i think first of all davey garcia
could have given you four or five
innings i believe that j
happ could have given you a
representative outing i think the reason
they did it was
they felt let's start davey garcia
against a team
that became the first team ever at the
end of the year to start
nine lefties in the lineup let's get
them to do that
and then we'll bring in hap and will
force them to flip the lineup
but again you're not dealing with dances
you can't be the you can't be the
smartest guy in the room
when albert einstein's in the corner
sipping a daiquiri you just can't
this is a really smart organization so
they read through what was happening
they never flipped their lineup
and moving to hap actually burned them
because
you turned the catcher into a power
hitter and then manuel margot later on
also hit a home run off a hat
everything that could have gone wrong
with that maneuver went wrong michael
kay here
on the rich eisen show and you have also
interviewed larry david
like uh we have here on this show so you
know
um the concept of when you say with all
due respect that does allow you to say
something thoroughly disrespectful after
that
you called the rays a senuan you
basically called them the pee-wee
hermans of baseball but then said with
all due respect after that that's not
that's not going to fly michael you need
to you need to say it first
and then call the raise the pee wee
herman's a baseball that's what that's
but i like to do things a little bit
understood
understood yeah but that's what i'm
about so does that make does that make a
rosa reiner the paul rubin's view
of of this pee wee herman equation
because this guy
but but after the theater incident i
mean this
uh you know what if this was old school
baseball would this guy already have one
in the chops right now i mean
it's unbelievable what he's this kid is
amazing
he is on fire right now and when you see
what he's done
and then luke voigt led the majors at
home runs right
the cardinals are a little short on
offense you wonder an organization that
usually makes pretty good decisions
all due respect did not make good
decisions with these two very
you definitely know how to workshop and
step up your game
there's no doubt about that all right uh
so i guess moving on then uh the jets
are as you know my favorite team growing
up and i do talk about it here
quite a bit not just because of the name
of the show but what's happening there
to me is a national story
because if they wind up being first
overall there is going to be and and man
they are earning it and and i don't know
if flacco is going to start
finding people in a more efficient way
than darnold had been
in the last four games and that greg
three
g williams is going to have his guys you
know let's just say
cut the personal foul penalties in half
let's just even go that
and that it's going to work out well
against kyler murray and arizona
you see arizona right in front of you
this weekend
and they took a guy from the pac-12 as
we know
and they said he's our future and then
they got the first overall pick
and spiked the whole plan do you think
the jets would do such a thing and i
know we're way ahead of the story but
the jets look
terrible michael what's the talk in new
york about
on this front everybody that we've had
on my radio show
said they have to take trevor lawrence
including mike tannenbaum and
tannenbaum's
a fan of darnold so i i also believe
if this guy is as good as they say and
everybody that we spoken to uses the
same comparison
the best quarterback to come out of
college since andrew luck
so if he is in fact that sam has not
shown enough
over the two plus years to tell you that
he is definitely the guy now he has not
been
quote unquote raised the right way he
has not been surrounded with the right
people
but if lawrence is all that i think
you've got to do that and i'm sure
you'll find some takers
for sam darnold you're not going to get
back um what's what
was essentially the third pick in the
draft for him
but you can cut your losses a bit now if
you want to go around building the other
way
then i guess you could get a herschel
walker sort of deal for the number one
pick and the jets certainly have a lot
of holes
but sam has to prove a lot more um
by that point and you know if they have
the worst pick in the draft then he
didn't prove much but
my question to you rich eisen big jet
fans yes sir
what happens if if joe flacco has a
great game
and they actually win this week now
when you say this are we talking planet
earth or what other place
are we talking about we're firmly on
planet earth so he has a really good
game and they win
and then sam's shoulder is better and
ready to go
adam gates is on a a week-by-week job
security
uh tour does he keep playing joe flacco
is chandler jones playing this weekend
michael and makai beckton's not even
practicing you know i mean please uh and
and
you know there's there the way that i
saw
the team that i've been seeing play the
one that that showed up in indianapolis
the one that on a short week
watched brett rippon do his thing and
then when he couldn't do his thing the
jets bailed him out with
six personal foul penalties i cannot
imagine that joe flacco
is able to find a jameson crowder when
everybody else knows that's who he's
going to be looking for
it's it strains the possibility here but
let's just we can play the game
you don't want to play the home version
of the hype no i will play the whole
version i will do that i will do that
i will play this with you whatever the
jets need to do
to get that first overall selection they
have to do and it kills me to say that
because the times that i have met sam
darnold
to call him a dream come true and a face
of a franchise is an understatement
he's great he is beyond great he so
deserves better
than than a team that changes coaches up
and then uh has uh you know
uh that coach swallow the free agency
signing of le'veon bell
only to have the general manager who
makes that decision
conduct a draft then get fired then
have the coach handle matters until the
general manager
is hired and then that general manager
waits
another full calendar year to jettison
the best defensive player that they have
prior to a covet season in which their
second best defensive player in mosley
opts out
and you trade them away for draft
choices leaving the evaluation of the
quarterback which is the most important
thing
completely wide open to the injury bug
which is bitten them
so putting it all together i think this
is a total mess that deserves
whatever needs to happen to turn this
into rich coat tight on steroids
and if that means the jets lose all 16
it'll be tough
but they've got to do it whatever they
have to do how does that sound
it sounds great it sounds like the
football version of phil jackson
selecting frank nilakina and then
getting fired a couple days later
now was that in dolan's talking points
binder that he brought to the set
with you when you interviewed him i
believe it was uh was that in there was
was that before the
phil jackson firing or the i think it
might have been i think it was in his
talking point
it all bleeds together what is it like
having
the most hated man in new york stroll
into your studio with a binder that says
talking points on it michael what would
you think when you saw that
interviewing dolan a couple of years ago
rich and i don't think this is what you
want to hear
i have actually spent time around him
off the air yes he's kind of like a
decent dude
this is no no no i don't say he's a
horrible human other than the way that
he does
act but other than that i mean
oh boy really he's got really good i
mean at that time he had a really great
person that was like
running interference with the media and
i i looked at the guy and
i why are you letting him first does he
know this is on camera
people are going to see that you know it
just didn't
make a lot of sense but again he got the
points out that he wanted to get out but
i don't think that they really
helped him they didn't serve the purpose
well look in the few minutes i have left
with you michael
um we've got jon bon jovi on in the
third hour
where does he rank for you being from
the new york metropolitan area where is
he well he was on center stage he's one
of the top center stage guests
he's he's one of the nicest people can i
tell you a quick story
we had him on center stage right yep and
he was great
and then they started the uh the arena
football league which he had on
the philadelphia soul right yes and they
had a big big um
a reveal at a manhattan club so uh me
and
and the guys from the show it was like
two years after we had him on center
stage
and i never had contact with him after
that and and we all went to the thing
just to get free food
and uh they all bet me um ten dollars
that he would not know who i was okay
and i said
all right i don't think he will but you
know well i'll bet the ten bucks there
you go
and we're just standing there in the
hall and he's walking around like
greeting people he comes by goes
mike how you doing bud he goes boy
people love that center stage that we
did that's the kind of guy john
bon jovi's now that you have to collect
double for that not only did he know who
you were
he he referenced exactly how he knew you
and and the reaction uh he gives you
what you want which is not only
recognition but uh
to hear how good of a time that he had
you've got to collect double or triple
from
that the only other guest who did that
well larry david and i have become
kind of friendly yes but the only other
guest who did that after a long period
of time of not seeing him was snoop dogg
five years after he was on center stage
he's walking by with his group of
friends at a super bowl party and he
stops he goes
this dude did the best interview with me
i've ever had in my life
i can't if i can't imitate snoop dogg
yes that
snoop dogg was the only other guy so
snoop dogg and john bon jovi i don't
mean to burst your bubble michael but he
told me the same thing after the super
bowl i'm sorry to say really
well he was after
one of the many reasons why i love you
michael kay uh best of your family and
your beautiful family that i see on
occasion on your social media
and um let's chat soon congratulations
to your family too great to talk with
you right back
congrats on everything with you sir
that's uh michael k
who i have known forever and a day
right here on the rich eisenhower